there simply is no freedom for the
people living in xinjiang
to talk about what is happening there
china makes it impossible
and the country has so far refused
demands for an independent un
investigation
into alleged human rights abuses in the
region
but evidence exists even if it must be
presented
thousands of miles away from china
itself in london
those who say they escaped xinjiang and
the chinese communist party's campaign
of repression there
bore witness
in the camp they didn't treat the
male prisoners as human being
they were treated less than a dog they
didn't they couldn't
walk out the door uh in a normal way but
they have to
crawl out and crawl in they enjoyed
watching them being humiliated
and their suffering was
for them is their joy the tribunal does
not have any power to sanction china nor
any backing from the british government
but it's a place for witnesses to put
their stories on the record
to tell them to a global audience i
don't think in third eye
i was chained with the chin as you saw
for four months
i was tied to the bed my
moment is limited to the 30 40
centimeters
area everything i do is there
and eating drinking and then the toilet
everything
[Music]
china has launched an aggressive counter
propaganda campaign
an attempt to justify the re-education
camps and other policies in xinjiang
it says its actions are entirely correct
but it still felt the need to attack the
london tribunal
the way the river the so-called
wiga tribunal is neither legal nor
credible
it is just another anti-china farce
concocted by a few people
many in the west say that what china is
doing in xinjiang is the
far greater insult not just to the law
but to human dignity
and the fact remains that a hearing like
in london will never happen
in china tom cheshire sky news